blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman so a texas man was arrested
with a rifle as well as 118
rounds of ammunition at kamala harris's
residence
the night before last a cnn reporter jim
schudo
tweeting on wednesday night around 9 00
pm eastern that quote
a texas man arrested outside vp kamala
harris's official residence at the u.s
naval observatory wednesday
was in possession of an ar-15
semi-automatic rifle
113 rounds of unregistered ammunition
and five 30 round magazines
according to a washington d.c
police report cnn
going on to say that the individual is
facing multiple charges
for the weapons as well as the
ammunition spokesperson for the d.c
police
said that officers went over about
quarter past noon on wednesday
because of a suspicious person based on
a bulletin that actually originated
from texas this individual traveling
from texas
detained by u.s secret service there had
been
a region-wide intelligence bulletin
about this individual
uh he is a 31 year old man from san
antonio
the rifle the ammunition were recovered
from his vehicle
it's unclear at this time what his
intentions were
but many charges carrying a dangerous
weapon
carrying a rifle or shotgun outside of a
business possession of unregistered
ammunition possession of a large
capacity
ammunition feeding device and the
individual
was um detained by
um i guess what you would call local
police
before secret service showed up we're
still learning more about what exactly
his motives were we don't yet know but i
think many of us can sort of
imagine and whenever this happens you
know this is i don't want to joke about
this
because what happened this is serious
and what happened in georgia
with the massage parlor shooting is also
serious and
insanely tragic with eight people dead
but
i started saying you know are we gonna
hear this guy was also just having a bad
day
as per the day before yesterday's uh
press conference with jay baker the
spokesman for the cherokee county police
was this guy just looking to improve the
country as we heard from republican
senator
ron johnson recently about the january
6th
rioters will the gun people say the 118
rounds including the unregistered ones
those are just for hunting as many gun
rights people say
uh you should be allowed to have what is
the explanation going to be on this one
from different people
and of course good thing that this guy
was caught
but um certainly not uh
something that is boding particularly
well at this time you know think when
barack obama became president
the number of death threats against the
sitting president
when that stopped being george w bush
and started being barack obama went
way up and um under
the trump presidency death threats
against the president again that rise to
the level where the secret service gets
involved and they're
considered serious went down and of
course there are people who are going to
say
that that this this is likely about race
there's no way to know that this
individual incident
is uh uh we we you know you can look at
broader data this particular incident we
don't know
um but my concern is
given all of the concerns over the last
two months since the january riots about
the role
of both military former and current
as well as law enforcement within the
rioters
i just want to make sure that the right
people are in the positions to be
preventing exactly this type of guy
from being able to do harm to
kamala harris or whoever it is that they
do want to do harm to
we will see as we learn more what the
explanation was why did he travel from
texas to dc
um with the with the rifle with 118
rounds
at this point we just don't know hey
this is um another one of those
we predicted it but then when you read
about it
it's like even worse than what you
imagined
we have now learned that employees at
donald trump's chicago trump tower
were all vaccinated early well before
they were eligible and
interestingly this may not be about
trump specifically
but it probably is we're not completely
sure yet and you'll understand why in a
moment
the vaccination at this trump building
was arranged by a hospital co
that lives in the building and that's 37
year old anosh ahmed
72 employees of trump's hotel and condo
tower
received vaccines on march 10 and 11
but city guidelines say that hotel
employees aren't actually
eligible for vaccination until march
29th so they were
almost three weeks early the mayor lori
lightfoot said quote
we have a finite amount of vaccine in
the city we've been really really
careful to make sure
we're using it in a way that prioritizes
the most vulnerable people who are most
at risk and most at risk of
spreading it adding we can't have
something like this happen again
now the hospital itself is uh located
in a mostly black neighborhood nine
miles from trump tower
it claims that its mission is to provide
vaccines to the quote
minority communities hardest hit
by the coronavirus pandemic but what
happened
is vaccines were taken from there and
brought nine miles
to trump tower it's sort of the epitome
of the worst of the worst now is it just
coincidence that
it's trump tower what i mean by that is
okay the coo anosha ahmed lives in the
tower
and uh maybe it was just what he would
have done
regardless of where he lived and it has
nothing whatsoever to do with the trump
family
except that anosha ahmed
bragged that eric trump was one of the
individuals
vaccinated and there's even a picture of
them together although it's not
immediately clear if this picture
is from vaccination day that we are
currently showing the audience
ahmed also sent to others a picture of
himself
posing with eric trump on march 13th
eric trump tweeted two pictures of the
chicago tower in the city skyline which
confirms that
he was in chicago right around the days
when this vaccination
at trump tower was supposedly taking
place
so it's not looking particularly good
the hospital initially said oh we were
confused
we thought that hotel employees were
already eligible but then we found out
that they weren't really
eligible that seems insanely difficult
to believe
if you're going to drive the vaccines
from the hospital to trump tower
and you don't even know whether uh
you're not even going to really check
whether the hospital workers are
eligible
uh they said they thought that the
hospital were or the hotel
workers rather were eligible so that
imploded
so their newest statement
is that well listen even if they weren't
yet eligible
a lot of those 72 vaccinated trump
employees
were black and brown which is just sort
of like
now you're gonna pull the race card
yourselves as the story crumbles
so it all stinks this is just one story
and there are hundreds or thousands of
stories
just like it most don't involve trump by
the way
read up on what's happening in argentina
where i was born
with vaccinations anything you can
imagine is happening there
functionaries of the government are
being caught with
literally thousands of vaccine doses in
the trunks of their cars
when they're asked what are you doing
with that they're saying oh i was
transporting them
you're transporting vaccines that
doesn't really make any sense the
governor of the province of buenos aires
so buenos air it's almost like new york
city and state
you have buenos aires the city and you
have buenos aires the province the
governor of the province of buenos aires
has been involved in under the table
vaccinations for prominent people they
even there's there's like a prominent
argentinian
authors and intellectuals who reported
they were offered vaccines even though
they don't qualify uh they live in the
province i mean this stuff is rampant
globally it was only a matter of time
until one of these
vaccination scandals touched the trump
family and this is the first one we know
of
uh taking place in chicago so we'll see
what else we can learn about it
one week from today friday march 26th
very special day we start
spring break for the david pakman show
no but in all seriousness
we're doing a one-day membership special
february the first part of march
it's not been great from the standpoint
of memberships a lot of people writing
saying david i've got to cancel i just
can't afford it i'm cutting this i'm
cutting hbo
i'm cutting cable and i get it so we are
doing a huge one day membership special
friday march 26th if you want to
hear about it on the day of with
instructions about how to sign up
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
and friday morning you'll get an email
telling you exactly how to sign up
we'll take a quick break we will hear
from you i want to hear
what is on your mind we will take some
calls via discord momentarily
and much more coming up today
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to
blinkist.com slash david pakman i've put
the link
right underneath this video let's go to
the phones by which i mean
the discord lines as we often do on
fridays you can find the david pakman
show discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord get into the waiting lobby
if you would like to talk to me let's
start today with
dylan from kentucky dylan you're on the
air what's going on
hey david can you hear me yes i can hey
yeah i wanted to
specifically uh talk a little bit about
the vaccine and some of the rhetoric
around um what we can do after we get it
so i know that we've that you've talked
a little bit about
being able to gather if everyone is
vaccinated
right but but what what is the
difference between
saying hey we can have small gatherings
of people who are
all vaccinated and say you know
a large gathering of everyone that is
vaccinated because isn't that
you know localized herd immunity i think
we need to be more optimistic
about the vaccine yeah i mean i think
that
your point isn't a crazy one which is
with vaccines that are
65 to 95 effective
if you have all vaccinated people in a
room whether it's four people
six people or 20 people the
odds of having both a vaccinated person
that somehow got it and then them
giving it to another vaccinated person
who somehow will get it obviously you're
talking about low percentages here but i
do think it makes sense to go in steps
and the other thing is most states right
now have limits on the size of
gatherings
anyway uh sometimes it's 10 sometimes
it's 20. so
once you say that the number for the
size of gatherings is different for
vaccinated versus unvaccinated it starts
to get kind of complicated anyway so for
me
it it makes sense if you're vaccinated
get together in a small group and you
don't have to wear masks if you're at a
person's home in many states there are
still mask mandates so
if you're out you might be in a store or
wherever
where you have to wear a mask anyway and
if there's going to be unvaccinated
people the unvaccinated people should
all be from one household
it all makes sense to me but i agree
with you that these vaccines are really
good
and what's safe for vaccinated people
probably is a bit beyond what the cdc
has said so far i don't disagree with
you there okay yeah that's
yeah i mean i guess you know there's
some
hesitancy still around the vaccine and i
even saw an article
yesterday about you know even once you
get the vaccine
nothing really changes yeah i think
that's bad i
i've said i've done a bunch of clips
where i if you're telling people nothing
changes why would people get vaccinated
i think it makes sense to be clear and
say
things do change it becomes very
unlikely you will get the disease
if you were to get it it becomes almost
a zero percent chance that you will get
it seriously
the israeli data is it reduces
transmission you can hang out and hug
and be without masks with vaccinated
people
you i think it makes sense to be very
clear that there there's a lot that
changes actually and the more people
that get it the more quickly it will
change
right right all right yeah that's that's
the main thing i wanted to bring up just
because
i i feel like there needs to be a higher
amount of optimism around yes and i
don't see that happening right now
i agree i think it's happening more and
the cdc guidelines were good and i think
soon we'll probably get
more more updates on those guidelines
but we need more more of the optimism
for sure these are game-changing
vaccines
right all right david i appreciate it
all right thank you great to hear from
you
uh always always love hearing from folks
from
all states from all states let's go next
to freddy from
tampa freddy from tampa you're on the
air
freddy from tampa please unmute you're
on the air
hey good afternoon david pakman how are
you i'm doing well thank you
i don't have a political question i
wanted to ask you
what's your favorite movie oh i don't
have a single favorite but that's like
saying what's your favorite book you
know how
uh i i don't know i'm not a huge movie
guy
but i couldn't possibly tell my favorite
single movie i don't know i mean uh
you know the land before time still gets
me i've loved that one since i was a kid
but
no i don't i don't know thank you so
much uh i love your show
thanks all right my pleasure sorry i
don't have a you know some people say
what's your favorite book and it's like
i don't know i you know
i'm reading three books every two weeks
it's it's really hard to say
let's go next to bobby from arizona
hey can you hear me yes i can how about
you bobby
i'm well um this is really exciting
because i've
recently discovered you og is like
maybe six or so months before the last
election so this is really exciting
is bobby short for roberta no it's
actually short just for just bobby joe
but oh that's a very common question
thank you well glad to clarify
uh so my question was going to be in
regards to arizona's
recent shift to blue and young
voters voting more democratic or more
independent i know i've got a few people
who don't necessarily
say that they're they're a democrat but
they they don't
they're definitely not republican so
with the shift in blue i know a lot of
it from what i've seen being in arizona
obviously i think has to do with uh
trump's you know decision to be
uh distancing or be rude to john
mccain's uh
legend he's really big out here
interesting so locally a lot of
republicans are
there they really didn't like when when
trump said stuff like i prefer
war heroes who don't get captured and
stuff like that there is actually a big
sign
the day after the election where is uh
trump's uh
uh face and john mccain's and it was
like john mccain like
came back from heaven it's a big local
thing out here and then the other part
of it i think is
there's gonna be more of a standing four
blue
uh just because of the young voters and
i was wondering if you had an opinion on
young voters turning blue
uh because i had an argument with
someone they're like no it's just
because john mccain i'm like it's
i don't think it is though no i think
it's more but so there's there's two
different things
there's are there more young people and
the young people are just more on the
left
or are you saying that there are young
people voting in arizona that used to
vote republican now or and now are
voting for democrats
so i know personally that's my case the
latter so i grew up in a
with uh with boomer parents and they
were very republican and that's all that
was fed
republican rhetoric so i had as soon as
i became older
and started actually interacting with
people um i did end up learning more
about the
world and then realized well that's not
really not fair but
not the right way that i feel like
should be done yeah so
more independent media more uh things on
youtube your show
i discovered and i realized more and
more about things that i wanted
versus what my parents wanted right so i
know personally that was my decision but
yeah i mean anecdotally there's i know
of a lot of that going on i know people
who voted
for joe biden in arizona who essentially
had never voted
for a democrat at the national level
since they became old enough to vote
it's of course anecdotal but it's
interesting that you're observing that
in arizona because
the p i know lots of people who are on
the left and didn't vote and then they
went out and voted for biden in order to
remove trump in november but those are
people who were always on the left
in arizona specifically i know people
that are exactly what you're
saying you yourself are which is they
actually used to vote for republicans
and then they voted for joe biden so i
don't know what to make of it these are
it's just anecdotes but obviously it
bodes well for the left in arizona
yeah no i think there's going to be more
of a blue shift and i don't think it's
just like a one-time thing
personally let's hope let's hope now how
are things going on
mask-wise are people because i know that
arizona has been some describe it as a
coveted hellscape
what how how is it feeling there right
now uh it depends on the areas like if
you go
to uh like north uh like the richer
areas it's
much more relaxed and then more i think
a lot of businesses
are taking more of the ownership on the
requirement
so it just really depends on the areas
that you go to i think it's a lot of
dependent on
uh whether or not you say anything like
i had gone to the store and i asked uh
there's people without mouse and i asked
associated i was like hey
do something and they they did but it's
one of those situations where
it just it's gonna take as a group as a
society i feel like to put the pressure
because i think more people will fold in
that situation i think you're right and
i mean listen
hopefully we can vaccinate quickly
enough that this becomes a non-issue
because some people are just not going
to wear masks
yeah i'm looking forward to when i'm
available i'm in the younger category
and i'm i'm relatively healthy i'm
staying more isolated i work from home
so
i'm willing to wait until it's available
for my group than
just rushing in but i do know that my
husband works in
grocery and they just opened it up in
arizona for grocery workers to get it so
i'm excited to have him
lots of states even in advance of may 1
are saying
18 plus 16 plus can get vaccinated so
let's let's hope so all right thanks
bobby for the call
oh thank you all right bobby from
arizona
very very good caller let's go next
to let's go to i don't know if this is
ally or ali from boise idaho
ali or ali from boise are you there
please unmute you'll be able to talk to
me
ally or ali last chance from boise idaho
all right that's too bad let's go next
to andres from zaragoza in spain right
hey how's it going david hey how are you
pretty good pretty good
i have more of a generalized kind of
hypothesis in general more than really
something uh specific to our politics
all right i'll go for a generalized
hypothesis in general
yeah yeah for sure um it's uh it's
basically the idea that
um success in uh
in politics at all kind of breeds
corruption so if uh
if you're if your platform
is that you are specifically not corrupt
that you are uh you know
for example uh we'll say bernie sanders
whether or not you think bernie sanders
is uh
actually corrupt is neither here and
over there but a lot of his campaign is
he's not funded by the billionaires you
know that he is
um uh very trying to show that he is not
corrupt but
uh uh platforms like that usually just
don't
just get you know stomped out by people
who
are being paid off more people who are
more corrupt right uh
because yeah because success breeds
corruption
in politics
is basically my my idea there so you
kind of cut in and out there but
basically i
i agree with you in the bigger sense
which is as i've said before
counting on the people who got elected
under the current system
to completely change the system is a
long shot
because they themselves are at risk of
being taken out of power
if they change the system that got them
into power does that sort of make sense
as a general principle
certainly yeah yeah so one of the ways
that i think this could change would be
term limits because if you term limit
people where
there's no advantage there's no no let
me go back there's less of an
obvious incentive for them to keep the
system that worked for them in place
because either way they're going to be
term limited
i think maybe we would get more people
really willing to to radically change
the system that got them elected that's
one idea that i think would help
oh that's that's that's absolutely great
yeah it's because i i i see
things like oh i forget how many it is
but mitch mcconnell is like
so many uh senate terms and it's
absolutely ridiculous
right no yeah absolutely term limits
just across the board
is definitely a step in the right
direction
but yeah absolutely i just think the um
just
the general just the way the the system
is created is
uh is is just yeah it just naturally
breeds corruption and stuff like that it
doesn't no doubt uh
generally represent the people they're
supposed to be representing and you know
republicans in the covetville
recently is a very good example of that
no question yeah no question i think
you're thinking about this exactly uh
exactly the way i am
absolutely yeah well thank you really
much david
hey so so so you live in spain but
you're an american
um no my uh my dad was actually in the
u.s air force so we met my mom in spain
right now i am uh actually living in
nebraska
uh if if you'll believe that but so you
tricked me
into thinking this was a more
interesting call by saying you were in
zaragoza
um i i'm originally from uh
um but uh but no i i i uh
right now i i i'm not living there no
but i all right well we'll
we'll allow it it strikes me as a little
dishonest but we'll allow it
okay sorry about it all right thank you
okay uh great take care thank you no i
appreciate the call very important issue
very important issue
we are counting on the people who
benefit from the system
to change the system in some sense that
makes no sense all right let's take a
quick break
if you're holding do not hang up because
i'm going right back to the phones
momentarily
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
okay there's continued interest in
speaking with me via discord
you can join the discord i think we've
got what eleven twelve
thousand of our viewers on our discord
server davidpakman.com
slash discord the waiting lobby is the
place to go
if you would like to talk to me let's go
next to
magnus from scotland magnus you were on
the air
magnus if you unmute yourself we will
all be able to hear you can you hear me
yes i can um
i don't really have a question about the
us
at the moment um but scotland has
our um national elections coming up in a
couple of months
right and i wondered if you had any
thoughts on that i'm not expecting you
to
but just in case you did you know i i'm
not informed enough to be able to
comment unfortunately
okay well that's all i've got thanks
well what's going on
vaccination-wise in scotland
uh we we're doing it differently to
england and i think we got our care home
and that lot of people done earlier than
england
i think we're about level at the moment
uh i think 60 year olds are being done
at the moment
when are you expecting to be able to get
vaccinated
two three months i'm in the last group
to be done
so i've not looked into it
and then how about as far as like uh you
know in the us
a big thing has been for example to
support the restaurant industry by
getting takeout or maybe you
you call it takeaway in scotland is this
something that people are doing to rally
behind restaurants in edinburgh
um i i've not been doing it i've been
cooking my own stuff fair just because i
like cooking
that's fair all right very good okay uh
magnus thank you so much for the call i
appreciate it
thanks all right magnus checking in from
scotland very important
let's go next to varun from new delhi
varoon you were on the air oh hey david
how are you um well how are you
i'm doing well okay uh i just had a
simple
question you know um barring for the
moment that the uh
minimum wage increase isn't going to be
passed that you know it's been removed
from the relief bill
yeah i mean it was removed from the
relief bill
if it had been passed and
you eventually got to a 15 minimum wage
how would that
affect you know the minimum wage
recipients
functional liquidity because if that
elevates them beyond the
qualification threshold like the minimum
for um
you know i guess broadly welfare
benefits so you know snap benefits
and uh you know low-income housing that
sort of thing
i mean basically all their money is just
going to go back into that stuff so you
argue
in favor of uh demand side stimulus but
you know how does that work out does it
have to be accompanied with other
you know sort of policies that you know
raise the uh
you know the income threshold to qualify
for these things so this is a great
question and the crux of the question is
if you make nine bucks an hour but in
addition you qualify for certain welfare
benefits and then you have some
total income for the year which is your
nine dollar an hour job
plus maybe you know 180 bucks a month in
food stamps you add it all together and
then you say okay
we're going to give you 15 an hour but
as a result of that you will
exceed the income threshold for some of
these
benefits do you really come out ahead
that's the crux of your question right
yeah basically yeah it's a it's a very
fair question
the answer is it depends
significantly on what's going on at the
state
level in many uh which is which is
different from for many people
but you have to account for a couple of
different things
one is is a 15 minimum wage
for example like alabama has no state
minimum wage so in alabama
or maybe it's mississippi maybe it's
both the minimum wage in some of these
states is the federal which is 7.25 so
15 is more than
doubling the impact there on eligibility
for programs
is going to be very different than in a
state that already has an 11
minimum wage and it goes to 15. and
that's going to vary
uh state by state you also have to
remember that a lot of people who
qualify for benefits don't actually
go through the process of getting them
because the they either don't know that
the benefits are available
or the system is cumbersome or
complicated or whatever the case may be
so while there's no question that there
are some people who will get a raise
from a minimum wage increase
and they'll lose something on the
welfare side
when you account for the difference in
money in the pocket versus a housing
subsidy
money in the pocket versus food stamps
people who don't understand
or avail themselves of these systems the
net benefit is still
significant but that doesn't mean what
you're saying doesn't exist
and i think it's important to consider
it oh
okay thanks all right no problem um
yeah these are like problems to solve
rather than reasons not to increase the
minimum wage you know if the minimum
wage should be higher on an inflation
adjusted productivity adjusted whatever
basis
you do it and then you figure out how to
solve that that problem
as an example that varun uh brought up
let's go next to adrian from san
francisco california
hello hello david can you hear me i
can't and you are fr
you're not calling in from san francisco
argentina right you're san francisco
california
i didn't even know there was one in
argentina many people don't today
many people don't hey david i wanted to
ask you about what are your thoughts on
you know having us
troops in the middle east seeing there
have been a recent delay
in removing troops from afghanistan i'm
asking because
there's one hypothesis where you know
troops are necessary to stabilize the
area and prevent insurgencies
but i'm really curious to see if you
think we even have an obligation
in the first place seeing the cost of
american lives and capital
yeah so we've been talking about this
really uh for almost two full decades
that that's the right i mean
the question fundamentally is that of
responsibility
if we cause a problem in the middle east
how long do we have a responsibility to
stay
for so-called peacekeeping purposes
and stabilization purposes i have no
clue
i don't know what the answer is and you
know we're we're in
some of these countries because of
decisions made multiple presidents ago
by george w bush
does but where does joe biden's
responsibility
go for the destabilization that george w
bush
bush's decisions brought to the middle
east i do not know what the answer is
i think that at a certain point you can
make the case
that if you say ahead of time to the
world community
and to everyone involved we
understand our role in creating the
situation
that was many presidents ago and much
foreign policy ago
we are announcing that every troop will
be gone by x date
let's work together to figure out how to
make that a real reality but the u.s
is getting out period and then you you
figure out what to do i would think that
that is that is at some point has to be
morally acceptable
but your question of if you broke it how
long do you have a responsibility to
continue fixing it is a good one
and i don't know what the answer is you
know david you make a really interesting
parallel to uh
reparations uh the case for reparations
by to the easy coats because
it's the same philosophical question of
if we broke something uh in this case
the horrible institution of shadow
slavery right you know how long does it
have to take until we have to uh
you know morally have the obligation or
responsibility to well i think that one
is a little different and more
complicated for for a few reasons one
is that there's a question as to whether
if you just throw money at individuals
on the basis that they are still
affected
by the way the system used to work
you're arguably ignoring elements of the
system today that still don't actually
work correctly
and and some folks believe that the
first step has to be to actually reform
institutions
rather than than financial reparation i
mean this is a bigger topic it's it's a
different topic than the one maybe
you're bringing up
but i think that it's it's even more
complicated arguably
yeah it certainly is hey david i am a
first time brand new listener to your
show so
keep it up all right thank you so much
appreciate the call very important
good substantive questions uh love it
okay let's go next to
oh this is interesting i don't think
we've ever had a call from uruguay let's
go to grisha
from uruguay which of course means
uh grasshopper eh yes grasshopper i'm
calling again
mr pakman i had a call with you a few
months ago oh you did i apologize i
forgot about it
no worries no need to apologize and
remind me are you
are you in you're in montevideo or are
you in colonia where
are you no i am in montevideo you are
here since like
five or six years got it okay i am
originally from
argentina i am from the patagonia
argentina oh all right beautiful
so well first i want to ask you if you
are doing well and i
really hope you do i'm doing well yes
thank you
and then i have a two really different
uh topics yeah okay one if it is not
possible i wanted to ask you in spanish
okay so i recently posted to my
instagram
uh i was able to obtain a dozen
essentially argentinian croissants which
we call in argentina
medialunas which means like half moon
and i think you can imagine it sort of
looks like a crescent moon
they were they were very good but it was
not exactly
what we would call an argentinian
medialuna but it was pretty good
okay much
and and then the second part for sure is
uh in english i wanted to ask about if
you have heard
uh this i think it's a kind of like a a
leak or a declaration about the
uh well basically the u.s
influenced brazil to not take the
sputnik vaccine
yeah what have you heard about that i
did hear about it i don't know i mean
has it has it been confirmed
yeah i have seen it in different uh
news sources yeah some from argentina
one that is literally like
sputnik news so it's kind of i don't
know
maybe you go for a different source than
sputnik news but yes i i know the
allegation has been made
yeah it has appeared because here norway
i do think that
basically the same happened because the
argentinian government
offered the uruguayan government the
vaccine yeah and they were the way in
government basically like looked to the
other
side and literally waited three more
months
to get any vaccine we recently like i
think the first week of
march we had the first xenovac vaccines
right so just a question is like do
you think this is kind of uh
what is left of the policy of
trump trying to uh influence all this
like latin america in general yeah i
mean listen that goes back
well beyond donald trump and because i
just i don't know the truth of that
story it's hard for me to comment on it
what i do know is that the the we have
this phrase here the proof is in the
pudding
other than chile vaccination in south
america has been a disaster
and i'm sure there are many reasons for
it you know in argentina you might have
seen they make this big
show of an erolinias argentina's playing
plane flying to moscow and then back and
they welcome it at the airport
heroically
and like nobody's getting vaccinated and
meanwhile chile with very little show
has one of the highest vaccination rates
in the world
and the highest in in south america it's
like emblematic of the ongoing
problems with a lot of these governments
yeah for sure
and then i want to just one little more
because it's a thought that i have
yeah um trump
talking about show he made a big show
about the
i think it's two billion dollars for the
for the
operation warp speed and yeah things
like that about that
and you have said that operation was
worth it
was a must like if he didn't do
something
to to to put vaccine on uh to work and
uh they that would it would be like
negligent basically
yes uh so i thought about like
maybe he did such a big movement and
he like moved a lot of money and he
didn't get any results
and that's why he might be oh there
might be some
of this influence to like hey don't get
any other vaccine because i have seen
like tweets and things like that about
not even getting the astra seneca about
sin or the xenovac
it's like anywhere else get like
uh don't get any other vaccine that is
not the
the us wants i mean listen just thought
i had it it's
it's you're it's totally speculative but
it's
it would be very consistent with the way
donald trump sees the world i think we
can say that
yeah it's full of speculation at 100
for sure i don't have any source but
yeah
well nothing else david big a big hug
america and have a beautiful day hey
grisha before you go one question when i
was in montevideo a few years ago
i went to uh correct me if i'm wrong the
the
the market downtown is it el mercado del
puerto
del puerto it was amazing and it's like
this indoor market with all these
different
you know uh food stands there were so
many
americans there humiliating themselves
and attracting a lot of attention is
that common that american tourists at
the mercado del puerto
embarrass themselves yeah they kind of
do and not only there
i work in a hotel that is basically on
the opposite side of uh
of montevideo yeah and right behind that
there is a really good grill you know
like
a really like a grill that is there
since the 60s so
they do know what they are doing and
it's really really useful to
to to see the faces of the of the people
serving they're like i cannot believe it
oh no that's what that's humiliating
never is there there are plenty of
people from anywhere in the world i
guess
getting humiliated er humiliated sorry
that's true markets everywhere all over
the world yes it's not unique to uruguay
or america all right grisha appreciate
the call thank you
for sure david have a beautiful day all
right you too all right guys
let's end on a perfect phone call i
don't know that we could have had a more
perfect phone call than that i apologize
as always that i'm not able to get to
everyone
but we'll keep taking calls and i'll
keep hearing from many more of you
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow let's get into audience
questions for the week first one is hey
david is being against immigration
necessarily
racist couldn't you simply be against
immigration but not for racist or
xenophobic reasons
yeah i mean listen this is i prefer to
deal in reality rather than in than
in hypotheticals of course it's possible
that you might be someone who
does not care about race or ethnicity
you're against immigration to the united
states
from any country for any reason
whatsoever
doesn't matter if it's a country of
predominantly white or brown people
or if it's a predominantly rich or poor
country sure that that exists
the reality is that um in in
uh of vast uh swaths of situations
the economic arguments that you often
hear made against immigration
really only end up applying to
or people are only thinking of those
from countries where the immigrants are
more brown or black
than they are white and we see this in a
number of different ways which we'll
talk about
you can for sure i mean listen first of
all
there are studies that show that racism
and anti-immigrant sentiment are highly
correlated now you could be racist
and against immigration for other
reasons that are not related to
race or ethnicity sure that that's quite
possible
but decades of data show us that
preconceived prejudicial notions about
wraith and race and ethnicity
tend to correlate with um anti-immigrant
sentiment now there are many economic
questions about immigration that can be
made we've analyzed many of them like
for example
immigrants are taking the jobs of
americans
immigrants reduce wages immigrants
are leeching off of the system and every
single one of these has
an answer and it's typically not what
the anti-immigration crowd
says one of the things i think is useful
when you're dealing with someone
who claims to be just against
immigration
period is to talk about a situation
in which the immigrants are
uh typically white from so-called
western age
nations and gauge the reaction to that
situation
and then talk about immigrants from
countries where people tend to be brown
or black
or at least the belief is when you talk
about immigrants from
mexico or haiti the people aren't white
and see if you get the same reaction i
mean
it's it's you know we can study these
things scientifically
and empirically and it's been done but
when when you have such a situation if
it's someone you know
gauge their reaction talk about
immigrants from norway and sweden
and then talk about immigrants from from
haiti or mexico whatever whatever the
case may be now
they may say well there i have a
different opinion
about immigrants from sweden versus
immigrants from haiti
but it's not because of race it's
because it's about
skill and i believe that
for no racially uh motivated reason
the people coming from sweden are higher
skilled
than the pers than the people coming
from haiti
the reality is that there's plenty of
highly skilled
computer programmers engineers
people in the medical field you know
accountants coming from
africa some of the top
engineering and programming people that
i know in the united states are from
argentina now there's an availability
bias for sure
me being from argentina i just know more
argentinians
also argentina's mostly white but a lot
of racists don't realize that they don't
know the difference between argentina
and mexico and you know costa rica or
whatever the case may be
uh but this is you know i'm reminded of
the situation with the israeli bds
movement where
in principle just saying for political
reasons israel should be boycotted
that's not anti-semitic
but the bds movement is a haven for
and provides cover for many anti-semites
whose reasons stated for boycotting
israel could apply to 10 other countries
which they either aren't even aware of
or are aware of but certainly aren't
interested or advocating in
in boycotting so yes you can be i mean
if you're just trying to get me to say
you can be against immigration and not
be a racist of course
of course now that we've gotten back
beyond the hypothetical
let's actually deal with the typical
reasons that are given for being against
immigration and see if they're applied
equally
uh regardless of of race or ethnicity
and you very quickly see how
it is a cover for lots of racists and
xenophobes
david who could actually defeat trump in
the 2024 republican primary
you know i don't know how to answer this
question unconditionally because
it all depends on whether republicans
still
like and support trump in 2024 we talked
with
bill share earlier this week and
he explained something that is
intuitive to many of us which is until
we know what happens in 2022
and we see whether trump is in or out of
favor
with republican voters and the
republican elected officials
between 2022 and 2024 how can we say
what the outcome would be of a 2024
primary with trump
as a candidate if donald trump still has
the majority of the republican
electorate behind him as he does today
nobody can beat him quite simply nobody
would be able to beat donald trump
if come 2024 the numbers are as they are
today
which is nearly two-thirds of republican
voters say if trump started his own
party
i would go with him and abandon the
republican party something like 85
percent of republican voters
want donald trump involved in politics
to some degree if donald trump
successfully plays kingmaker in 2022
because people donate to his save
america pack
and then he successfully primaries some
so-called rhinos that he doesn't like
republicans in name only basically
republicans that don't like trump like
mitt romney
if trump gets his you know the kawthorne
bobert marjorie taylor green types
re-elected
and runs in 2024 nobody's going to be
able to defeat trump
in the republican primary the general
election is another question
on the other hand if the republican
party
abandons donald trump anybody
could defeat donald trump if the donald
trump that runs in 2024
is sort of down and out all of his
friends have lost in 2022
the republican party has moved away from
him and it's become
very clear that joe biden's um
pandemic response uh was the right
response and just
humiliates the failed response from
donald trump in 2020
um then trump really has no shot and a
lot of this has to do
with the midterms we don't know who will
be
re re-uh revived through the midterms
if people like kawthorne bobert and
greene are re-elected in the midterms
then donald trump could be sailing on
the wings of
them and even more trumpian candidates
to 2024.
uh on the other hand uh it could go very
differently if the midterms don't go
well for republicans bill share said
earlier this week that he has this
hypothesis
that one party has the
has to lose the white house three times
in a row before you see real
introspection
and change if he's even partially right
trump merely losing in 2020 is not going
to be enough
um what we see over the last several
weeks
is that while trump's polling is still
strong within republicans
his political stature is diminished
search interest in trump is being
diminished
his public statements seem particularly
pathetic like when he put out that
statement saying
please remember when you get the vaccine
that it's thanks to me
it was increasingly pathetic so we'll
have to see what happens in 2022
it's not clear to me that democrats get
killed in the midterms
traditionally the expectation is when a
party
takes the white house from another party
in one year
in the immediate midterms two years
later they get crushed
doesn't always happen but but it often
does i don't know that it's going to be
the way it goes in 2022 i think it's
just early but i think there's a lot of
reasons that democrats could actually do
okay if there is not and a lot of this
has to do with covet and the economy
barring some like terrible covet variant
mutation
that completely outruns the vaccines we
have a vaccination program right now
that's going
well and we are likely to have uh
modified boosters
from pfizer and moderna maybe as soon as
the fall may be january which will deal
with
the newer variants if we deal with the
pandemic
vaccination continues going well and it
will be attributed
at least partially to joe biden taking
over he got the stimulus bill done
if the economy does well and the economy
is expected new goldman sa listen
goldman sachs love them or hate him
their timeline
last april about the pandemic was
exactly right they predicted late
november early december healthcare
workers will start being vaccinated
exactly the way it went they said here's
when the final
you know the big peak is going to be th
goldman sachs just put out
a prediction an analysis a forecast
that 2021 is going to be very good
economically for the country
if all of that happens it's not clear to
me that democrats go down in november of
2022. now
it's still a ways away we're still you
know 21 months or something from that
period and a lot can happen between now
and then but if biden essentially is
seen as the guy
who reopened the country did vaccination
and beat the virus i think it's tough to
say
republicans do super well in 2022
and that probably doesn't bode
particularly well for donald trump in
2024
all speculative all early we'll wait and
see
david do you think it's a problem that
people are making
huge amounts of money from the
development and manufacture of
coronavirus vaccines listen
i think that my view on this will
probably anger most people
other than like social democrats that
are exactly in my political space
i think there has to be a middle ground
on this now on the one hand
we as bernie sanders recently said we
can't allow these pharmaceutical
companies
to hold governments and and humans
hostage
when it comes to something like health
as i've said before
demand for health care services and
medications and vaccines is inelastic
what i mean by that is i my appendectomy
right
up until the day at which my appendix
swelled and became painful
i don't care what the price is for
appendectomies i don't want one i don't
need one
and then all of a sudden when i require
an emergency appendectomy
they have me over a barrel i need an and
i
i must find a way to pay any price for
an appendectomy
because healthcare services and demand
is uh is
is completely inelastic so we need
health is what we would call a special
case it can't just be left to
um the the free market now on the other
hand
as i've said before as a social democrat
i don't need i'm fine with the market
dictating
what video game consoles get made and
who makes them and what they charge i'm
okay with that i'm fine with that
mobile phones i'm okay you know i don't
need the government involved in
regulating mobile phone
prices i think that the market and with
that as a consumer product it's
i'm fine with that assuming that
everybody's playing within a regulatory
framework and to some degree the
the smartest best people we have
are going to be more likely to line up
to do
things like developing a vaccine for the
virus quickly
if there is something there for them now
many people will point to russia and say
well look at
russia russia developed the sputnik
vaccine
basically as quickly as the modern and
pfizer vaccines were developed
and because they did they didn't even
finish testing it
they they started using it even more
quickly if you
understand the authoritarian nature of
russia
you would realize that although it did
happen essentially as
quickly as pfizer and moderna which
which we will talk about
it wasn't just because out of the the
the good will
and desire it took place you're talking
about an authoritarian situation there
uh as we've been talking about for
decades at this point in time so i mean
listen the turkish couple in germany
that developed what is now called the
pfizer vaccine
they are now very wealthy they uh
invested time and money in developing
the vaccine and now
there is a payoff if there was
absolutely no payoff then would they do
it again
i mean maybe not and you look at pfizer
pfizer increased revenue
two percent after investing billions of
dollars
in r d in production on this vaccine
um is that bad i mean two percent yeah
it's a huge company it's a huge
amount of money you could apply the same
logic to
researchers of other vaccines
don't we want people entering the field
of science
and developing things that can be
life-saving
of course we need to ensure access of
course we need situations where things
are subsidized
of course bernie is right when he says
you know the the
patenting of these vaccines when it
comes to
them being produced in other countries
we need to take control of this we can't
do it in a way where other countries are
prevented from making the vaccine of
course we need to do all those things
those things but at the same time
we want to incentivize people to get
into these fields if the belief
is the way you make a lot of money is by
you know i don't know
becoming a celebrity or an athlete
or a um you know high-priced lawyer or a
consultant or whatever
and then people don't get into these
fields of medical research that we're
all worse off so
i believe there has to be a middle
ground um maybe the government needs to
be involved
in in determining what are fair prices
you know all of these things have
caveats but context
is crucial and when you say
should it be possible for pharmaceutical
companies to hold the world hostage
charging 300 per vaccine dose no
no that shouldn't be possible should it
be okay
for people that are developing
life-saving technologies to be rewarded
in a way that's commensurate with what
they are doing yeah to some degree that
should be okay and you know what if they
make a ton of money they should pay a
lot of taxes
and all of the other economic policy
that we and bernie and others have been
talking about i think context is key
and there has to be a middle path here
um and i'm curious to hear from you
uh where you fall on this issue make
sure you are a member
at joinpackman.com to get access to the
bonus show
otherwise i'll see you on monday
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman